what is going on everybody and welcome
to part three of the reinforcement
learning with stable bass lines 3
tutorials
in this video what we're going to be
talking about is indeed using custom
environments the main crux of using a
custom environment involves basically
just doing this converting your
environment to a gym environment sort of
structure
but it actually gets far more
complicated than that and arguably the
hardest part is actually coming up with
what will your observation space be and
what will your reward be so with open ai
gym environments um
all that's been it's just been handed to
you and um it's actually very simple
because
um
you don't even have to think like what
would be a good observation what would
be good features to be input into the
reinforcement learning algorithm it's
just it's just done for you same thing
with the reward so what would be an
actual good reward so reward and
observation are not necessarily as
obvious as you might think they might be
so uh first we're going to need some
sort of environment so if you're wanting
to follow along with your own
environment that's totally fine
you can do that or you can use the
environment that we're going to use here
and then take what you've learned to
your own environment it's really up to
you so
yeah so the one that we're going to use
is just the snake game i really just
searched the internet for a snakey game
i landed on this one made sure the game
at least worked because they don't
always work and uh it does and i think
this would be a fairly simple
environment to convert it's also a nice
kind of short simple game so it won't
take us hopefully too long to convert it
to a gym environment so uh with that in
mind let's go ahead and first we'll
convert this just all to like be like
one script so copy paste that and i will
copy
paste that
and then finally
one more
copy
and paste
go ahead and save that and
uh
we don't need to be doing the writing to
the d drive i don't even
have one
cool so we'll go ahead and save that and
let's go ahead and also
run that so snake game let me just make
this nice and big python three snake
game dot pi
and here we have the game it's w a s and
d for control also you could just in
theory not press any key and i'll just
do whatever the last direction was and
the idea here is you're the green thing
the snake and you want to get the apple
let's see if we kill ourselves no we got
it nice so anyways as you get an apple
the snake gets longer it becomes harder
and harder to actually get the apple so
the question is can we create uh
you know can we make this an environment
and then get a reinforcement learning
agent to solve this environment
so the first thing that i'm going to do
is actually speed up this environment
just slightly because that is uh really
slow so first of all it's slow because
of this so i'll make this 0.05 and then
also for the weight key i will just set
that to be one so coming back over here
just to test that make sure that worked
and in indeed it does so i'm sorry so
it's too fast for me to play but i think
our ai will be fine
so uh let's go ahead and close out of
this
so now that we've done that let me
i'm just going to move this terminal out
of my way i know you don't see it
anymore but
it's still in my way
okay and now what we want to do is
convert that to an environment so again
we'll come back to here and i'm just
going to copy and paste this
there is a text based version of this
tutorial so if for whatever reason if
i'm copying something and you don't know
where it's coming from or whatever uh
you can copy and paste from there also
if if anything you know fails you in the
conversion uh i'll have a text-based
version really what i'm trying to get
you to grasp here is what are the steps
required uh to really convert an
environment and then
the subsequent video will almost
certainly be okay well now how do we
tweak and think start thinking about
observations and rewards so anyways
that's really what i'm trying to get
across here rather than you know you
need to follow along exactly so i'm
going to copy this and one thing to
think about is
i keep meaning to submit a pr someone
can feel free to submit one i don't
really care
everything else on stable baselines
three is a four space tab indention for
some reason this little script here is
two spaces
uh i wish they didn't do that if anybody
from sp3 is watching just fix that for
me real quick
it's been very tedious copying from
there whoops i don't want to do that i
want to come over here uh so snake env
and we'll just paste that in so now what
we want to do is we want to convert um
basically everything from snake game
over here to m to do that uh i kind of
just want to like cut and paste so
i'm going to just do this copy
come over here paste
and i think i really will just cut that
way i know that i've left something or
not
um
actually i guess it doesn't really
matter
i don't know i can't really decide what
i want to do there um maybe i won't cut
so we definitely need those helper
functions and all that now coming down
into and we'll just leave those outside
of the actual object here for the
environment we'll call it uh i don't
know we'll call it snek
env
and when we go to super we will also
super snekem
for now we won't pass any parameters to
the init method we there are some that
we might wind up doing later for now
i'll just leave it empty um
discrete actions we already know this
will be four
and then for observation space we
actually do not know at this time uh
what will the observation be we haven't
thought of that yet so we will get there
uh we'll get through when we get there
which will be pretty soon um so the next
thing i want to do is just address the
next logical step which is as soon as
you initialize your environment really
all we need to do in the initialization
of the like gym environment object is
set the action space in the observation
space the next thing that gets called is
actually the reset so before you can
start stepping in an in an environment
you need to call the reset method for
this reason i would actually kind of
think of the reset method as your
initialization method for the actual
environment itself so not the gym enviro
not the gym object for your environment
right that's this method but in this
reset method that's probably where you
initialize all your other stuff
so
and also i'm going to get rid of close
and render close would be if you need
your environment to be cleanly closable
you might throw something in there and
then render i don't really care about
that i'm going to render either way so
i'm just i'm just going to get rid of
that
so we're literally going to render
everything in in step anyways so i just
don't care
so
um so logically the next thing that
happens is the reset method so we're
going to tackle that one next in fact i
kind of am noticing the screen is a
little or the text is a little small so
we'll zoom in
a wee bit it's probably a little absurd
but there you go you cell phone watchers
uh so we'll come over to snake game
and
basically
the initialization for sure
is like this stuff right before the tr
like while true that is in theory like i
was saying before you can think of step
as like your frames so while true the
frame is resetting every single time so
at least in this case
basically it's this information here
that will be our
the initialization of our environment
and in our case will be the reset method
so we'll come down here
and
i just told you about the two-space
indentation and uh
i never fixed it shoot
i can't remember in
vs code if i can just can i get away
with like that no no not quite
there's some way to like do it all in
one fell swoop
someone will comment below i'm sure
anyway this is good enough i think right
or did we just
oh my gosh
am i am i that
i don't know what i did oh my gosh okay
we're good i think
okay anyway so i'm going to paste this
code in here we're going to tab this
over and really at this point because
the game or the environment that we're
attempting to convert here was not
already in like object oriented
programming uh syntax uh it's going to
be a lot of self dot editions um so
you know
yay
so so here we go um so we'll start off
with uh self.reset uh i think also even
though this says done info can't be
included it's really just about the
return we could still in theory
calculate a reward done and info if we
really wanted to
and one of the things that we're going
to do is we are going to set self.done
to false because every time right before
like as you iterate over your
over your episode when an environment is
done you will do it a reset so when we
do a reset what are the things that we
want to reset well we definitely want
done to be false
so now
what i'm going to do is copy self dot
and uh yeah i guess we're just gonna do
a lot of self dots here yay fun
awesome i love it
my favorite thing to do uh and then
we'll make that self.observation um even
though we haven't defined an observation
yet i understand um
okay i think we're good so now we need
to talk about the observation so what
ought the observation be so my proposal
for an observation
let me zoom in a little more
i think we want to know where is the
head of the snake right we want to know
that so we would want like head x
and head y
then we would want to know where is and
head x would be this and head y would be
this and i might have those
flipped because we're doing
everything's in like a grid with
what appears to be numpy and opencv i
think y and x and y are like actually
flipped so like this is probably the y
and this is the x
um so if you want to comment below
furiously that i've got it wrong that's
okay we could just call it head a and
head b because really all that matters
is we have even if it's flipped as long
as everything was flipped we'll be fine
so
so i acknowledge that it actually might
be flipped but anyways head x head y we
wanted to then know the apple
x apple y
apple y
um
and
uh then we also want to know the
snake length
snake length and then finally we
probably want something about previous
moves
so um
so the snake needs to be aware of its
body and you might be thinking well
why aren't we just passing the entire um
uh you know this basically why aren't we
just saying the observation is quite
literally self.image right
and you can do that feel free to do that
if you really want to do that but
my argument here is
that's a lot of noise so in general with
machine learning you want to whittle
down the noise as much as possible and
passing that entire image is just mostly
noise right it's almost all like black
space and to be honest i don't know that
there's any other than being easier to
code and like less things that you need
to think about i don't see the benefit
there so instead what we're going to do
is just do some feature engineering
where we just want to know where's the
head of the snake where's the apple
and then how long is the snake and then
what were the snakes like previous moves
and my expectation is that the ai could
extrapolate the previous moves
basically extrapolate
you know where is the snake's head
how long is the snake and what were the
previous moves and then it would know
like it could know where
the rest of the tail is essentially um i
think that that is suddenly the most
complex part of this entire thing for
the agent to learn and maybe it never
learns that maybe instead it just simply
learns to take certain actions that
don't result in death
and that's fine and if you want to come
up with something else that's totally
fine too just obviously the observation
needs to be a fixed size so you couldn't
you can't really make this like where is
each set like what's the location of
segment two in segment three instead i
mean you sort of could like if it didn't
exist you could say it's a negative one
or something like that um
i don't know like i said i'm just trying
to show you guys how to make your own
custom environment but yes i acknowledge
that there's probably better ways to do
this
so now uh with that in mind let's go
ahead and um start defining basically
what what all these are so head x will
be
self.snakehead
zero
and
we'll make head y this would be so much
easier if with copilot on i kind of i
turned co-pilot off um because i think
it would be detrimental to uh tutorial
videos but um comment below if you have
an opinion either way because it would
make things like so much faster if i
could just leave copilot on
like stuff like this is so tedious so
we've got head x head y now we need to
get the apple x and apple y um and
actually
i kind of want to make this apple
delta
delta
x and y i'm trying to decide which would
make more sense to make it a delta or
like the actual position
i don't know that it would really matter
if it's a delta or if it's not a delta
then i think the agent would just have
to do the calculation right
um
and again this is just back to my
original point that you know coming up
with the observation or yeah the
observation on the reward is kind of the
challenging part but anyways we'll call
it apple delta
x and we'll say that's head x
minus apple
didn't we have apple something apple
position that's actually self.apple
position
hello
okay thank you
make sure it's not running over yeah
okay um something happen position
zero
and then again
i wish i had copilot right now
uh y we'll make this a one we make this
a y and we make this a y
fantastic so okay so we've got the
deltas
now we need snake length
so
uh snake length and that will be quite
literally the length of
snake position so snake position
contains like all these uh like two you
know just the coordinate positions for
each of the little snake squares so as
we get more of them this just gets
longer and longer so really we just want
to know what is the len of self.snake
position
len of self dot snake position okay so
once we have that uh we do okay we reset
the screen we have these so this is
basically our observation
um up to this point except for we really
want to have
the previous actions so self.prev
actions will be equal to we need to
import a deck subject deck and then max
len will be equal to
um
i don't know snake
len
goal
okay we have a lot of things that we
need to hurry up and not forget about so
we'll come to the tippity top
from collections i'm going to import
deck and then i'm just going to define
this as 30 for now
um so again because of how we need we
need this to be not dynamic we need it
to be affixed so we're just going to say
hey we want to it we want to
shoot for a snake to be up to 30 little
units long um
i'll call it a win if we make it that
far
um so coming back down here
okay so now again this is our in it so
we need this deck to actually be filled
completely before we get going so what
we're going to say is for underscore in
range uh snake len goal
we are just going to populate self
self.prev actions
with a negative one so it just populates
with negative one which will hopefully
be
learned by the agent that that means
nothing
so our actual usable actions will be
zero one two or three
okay so now that we've done that we can
actually create the observation so we're
gonna say
self.observation is going to be equal to
and we'll make it a list for now head x
head y
apple
delta x apple delta y
um
snake length right snake
length and let's go ahead and fix this
typo
length like that
and then finally we will just plus
and add the list
of
prev
actions
awesome um and actually it's
self.pre-reactions because we do need to
continue to be able to reference that so
let me come back over here
self.preve actions cool
okay
so that's our observation
let me zoom out a little bit just so
just in case anybody missed anything
okay
i think it's good enough
so now what we want to do is get to the
stepping part
so
for the actual stepping we'll come back
up here
i'm going to get rid of this
and make some space there make sure that
is still self.observation i'm gonna go
ahead because i
i'm pretty confident i'm gonna forget
about this so we'll add self dot
self dot
uh self.done yeah uh info because i'll
probably forget about that as well we'll
just make that a empty dictionary
save that
and now we're ready to step
so every step what happens essentially
all of this code this is all step code
right here so
so
i am going to
do i want that wait key 0
i know i don't want that break i'm not
sure about that weight key 0. we're
going to copy everything for now
uh so copy that come over to snake enve
and
we will paste
and then i need to tab everything over
twice apparently yes okay
all right no why did that why did that
get tabbed over
i don't think i did that
i'm not sure what happened
i swear uh vs code does stuff like that
to me all the time
anyway okay
now um
i can't really decide if i want to run
through here first and do all the self
dots or i don't really know what i want
to do
uh either way it's going to be painful
we're going to definitely forget some
self dots
okay self.image so we show the image we
wait keyone
self.image again cool cool everything's
good there rectangle self.image apple
position
gotta be a self.apple position every
single time
again if you don't want to do this uh
feel free to just wait
hit copy and paste it self.snake
position cool we don't need to this is
just a temporary variable but this does
boom
cool cool got it got it got it coming
down here um all right in this case uh
what do we want to say um
i actually think that we don't need any
of this code
because this is just determining what is
our button direction well we don't
really need that and in fact we don't
even need this it just should be action
if action is one we do this thing
if action is zero why do they go that
way that's interesting anyways action
action not my code
uh coming back up here just to grab a
self dot real quick copy copy come down
here okay self.snakehead
self
self
self
cool
uh increased snake length if it ate an
apple great we're super happy if that
happened
awesome apple position and self.score
equals this and again
boom
boom so many self dots
i wish there was like some sort of ai
like in github co-pilot that just knew
and it just added all the self dots that
would be awesome
cool coming down here self increase so
if it didn't okay self. self dot
self dot oh so tiring
okay collision snake head cool
um
i'm getting ahead of myself i'm back
thinking back about this weight key i
don't think i want that there um okay so
if we collided what do we do we're going
to say font yes fine uh we are going to
reset self.image
uh
put text self.image
format self.score
show self.image
and we are not going to do this
and this is a collision so if this
happens we do want to say self.done
equals
through
um
all right
i'm sure i've messed something up along
the way that so many self.dones or self
dots rather
i can't even think straight so okay now
that we've done that we just need to
calculate two more things one is the
observation one is the reward for the
observation i'm quite literally going to
just copy
everything we did right here boom
very simple
um so that's done so we have our
observation i believe now we need to
calculate the reward now in the case of
the reward again this might seem like oh
my gosh that's so simple the reward
should just be what is the length of the
snake or the score or whatever i don't
even i can't
where was he calculating score anyways
um
is it just at the very end
uh
where does he calculate score
self.score so when is self.score defined
okay sorry
[Music]
okay so it's only updated at the apple
point
so we could say the reward is the
self.score
um
and just try that
is so is that the first definition of
self.score
okay so he starts at zero self.score is
zero zero zero so you could just wait
um
okay so here's what we'll do we'll say
where am i
so reset sometimes so we'll just come
i guess like right here
so let's let's create the reward so if
if self.done
uh we're going to say the reward is and
actually it should be i think
self.reward i think we threw self in
front of that self.reward equals
negative 10. so if the snake dies for
whatever reason we'll say it's a
negative 10
and then else hello
else
self.reward
c word
reward equals um i guess we could just
say self.score right so it should be
like
hm apple's eaten
okay i think i think we are ready-ish
for a moment of truth so uh the next
step is
coming over to using custom environments
um stable baselines three has given us a
sort of check m
functionality
so we'll come over to checkout.pi paste
that in
uh custom m is snekm
snack m
no parameters were passed and we will
from snake m import snack m
save that um oops
i
think
we're ready to see how many times
oh and also my snake my other snake game
is apparently still up
back
already
i'm not sure what the heck just happened
uh check m check m dot pi
um not positive
uh do we remove self from the init
method maybe
i can't think of what else would have
happened yeah okay
i guess that's
alrighty
i'd love it if that was the only error
please no
oh right we never revisited um this i
knew that was gonna happen okay so uh
coming back over
so uh we we knew our discrete spaces
will just be four uh the observation
space uh in theory the delta so
head x head y could be anywhere from
zero to 500
uh delta
could be
anywhere between
[Music]
zero
what that what could that be
it could be up to negative 500.
um
so in that case we need this
oh i got lost
low was a low negative 500 high positive
500
i don't actually know uh if
these values serve any purpose other
than just for like sanity checks so you
might even be totally fine and safe to
just say low is negative np.if high
positive np.m
that might be good enough i don't know
um and then shape we actually just have
a vector here of values so it should be
um
it'll be what's uh
it'll be essentially the snake length
goal plus
however many other things we have so one
two three four five so five plus snek
len goal
so five
five plus snake line goals that's our
observation um also do not forget don't
forget your little comma right here
right this is for the shape so you can't
just put like a single ink in there it's
a tuple add that comma so next
data type uint it's definitely not uint
i think our data is acceptably an intate
but i'm actually just going to say
mp.float32 so i don't have to actually
go through and convert all those because
i think that's the default data type for
all numpy arrays um
feel free to change that if you want i
don't care um
i just want this to run
i'm just trying to show the most basic i
can so we'll run that please
collections
oh
dot append so we didn't do a an append
there on line 147 hey we made it a long
way so far i'm okay self.previous
actions
don't
append although we only made it to the
reset but we made it pretty far in the
reset so
hey that's boating well
the observation returned
must be a numpy array we never converted
it okie dokie
self dot observation equals np dot
numpy.array
self.observation
i was literally just talking about that
and acknowledging that it's a numpy
array and then i
forgot to do that awesome
so i'm just converting both in the reset
and the step method um to make sure it
is indeed a numpy array
oh we made it so far
actually what
brave did i copy that what did i do
there
oh dear
oh dear
how did i make this mistake
so okay first of all we did not append
the action so we definitely need to say
uh
self.preview actions dot append
action and then coming down here
i've got no good explanation for why and
how i left that in
actions
because
at least in my head i guess this was all
like observation stuff i didn't
recognize that
okay let me make sure this is what i
want uh
[Music]
okay yeah so we'll just delete that
so we really only wanted that line to
occur that's a good thing good thing i
forgot the append i would that dude we
would have left that in there
that would have been a nasty bug i would
never have caught that somebody would
have told me i'm sure okay so quick
check em uh it does appear that things
are indeed working it's it's so quick
when you run check em so the next thing
is sometimes i've missed certain things
by just simply running checkm like
checkm can't actually check like
literally everything in your environment
some things are just
need some logic so i would recommend you
also i just made another script called
literally double checkm and all it does
is just 50 episodes it runs through and
does a random action just so you can
literally see the actions and rewards
and make sure everything is kind of like
what you're expecting it to be um
and so i would also just recommend this
again i would just go to the text based
version and grab it there's nothing
fancy here um python python three double
check m
yeah i mean that looks good uh the
reward negative i mean he never actually
gets the apple so
um
shouldn't it have a reward of
of zero at some point though
let me think here
uh like i feel like
the reward was always
negative 10.
so reset
self.score gets reset
we're going to also just reset reward
equals zero
how come um
and this is what i mean this is why i
think it's important to run it again
uh
y is self.done equals true
self.reward is negative 10 otherwise
i think this should be zero
right i mean i think that should be zero
every time
i'm not sure what the wild true is while
not done
right shouldn't that be let's run that
okay
so it resets reward zero zero zero zero
negative ten boom cool
okay so high punishment for death um
probably a pretty low punishment for the
actual uh score i might even suggest you
know before we even waste any time is um
maybe self.score because score would is
just going to be a plus one so i might
even say self.reward is self.score
uh times 10. so at zero it's nothing but
if we did ever get an apple uh it would
be
rewarded relatively decently
okay now what i want to do is come over
to where we've been working let me make
that maybe a little bigger oh i wish i
could make it even bigger but okay
and basically what i'm gonna do is take
part the part two video i'm just gonna
copy and paste that and we'll make this
uh
p4 snack
learn whatever um we just mostly want
that code so we're going to open up vds
here
we don't need that we aren't going to
use a2c we will use ppo
so i'll actually copy ppo that will be
the model that we use
our m will be
double check em doo doo doo snackin so
actually we'll do this
uh come over to snake learn
paste
cut that
paste that
wonderful this will be ppo
uh and in fact
[Music]
we're gonna make the model during the
time that time so that's fine um
we don't need any of this
uh this should be ppo probably
i don't actually we're always gonna use
ppo so
i'm not gonna give it it'll just be
time.time
um
we definitely want to do more than this
so i'll just say i'm just going to say
wow true and just let this go for a
while
so wow
true we do that um actually no we kind
of want that i huh um we could just do a
counter or i can do this
okay
i think that's good so now
what was this p force neck learn
python 3 p4 snek learn
make sure that actually begins something
okay i think it's off
okay i'll just leave this stuff up let
it record for a while hopefully this
will update i'll check on it in a little
bit i don't really expect the greatest
results but we will see um how it does
anyways so uh i will check back with you
guys in a bit all right so i've left
this running for quite some time about
41 000 steps into training uh the agent
has improved uh it's not an incredible
agent but you know we haven't done that
many steps yet
but
really we probably could tweak some
things and make pretty drastic
improvements here so
checking the results the episode length
has increased quite a bit and that's no
surprise because there's no punishment
for staying alive and there's a minus 10
for death so that makes sense that this
has worked out um and then our episode
reward has been slowly but steadily
improving
um again it's possible that with more
time more episodes we could actually see
even more improvement and this might
even continue trending up at least right
now it does look like an upward trend so
that's pretty cool now coming over to
the code i already forgot did we
do a times 10 we did on the score so
this is with the times 10 so we've
already you know tried to reward it
heavily for eating apples
but it doesn't seem to matter so
so
so i think what we need to do is give it
a little bit more help to actually get
to the apple so that's what we're going
to be focused on in the next video this
video's idea and the whole point was to
at least get us started with a custom
environment and then yeah in the next
video we'll talk about okay well how can
we do better feature engineering maybe
change the reward a little bit how can
we
get this agent to hopefully learn faster
at least be better than what it is right
now in 40 000 steps so
that's all for now if you have questions
comments concerns whatever you know the
deal feel free to leave them below if
you've got uh if you want any of this
code like you didn't feel like copying
and pasting all those self dots no
problem there is the text based version
of this tutorial it is linked in the
description so anyways that's all for
now and i will see you all in another
video
you